it's crazy because like you say you've
had
some runs right like i think we all know
your first
kind of run or introduction to
everybody kind of knowing that who
hitboy is
was watch the throne yeah that era of
working with yay
and and um in paris is one of the most
iconic songs
yeah yeah yeah you already ever like
that that wave
had to be like it it you know from there
you you you you was on
you know working with riri and and there
was abroad
a crazy run um i felt like
at that time i was real close with my
dude lifted who did mercy
who was working with kanye what what um
shout out to the um
yeah but what um because why didn't we
get more music with you and yay
man bro look this is the thing and
that's that's why it's another
like it's another part that's you know
my story that's disconnected because you
got to think about it bro
i was assigned to good music for two
years right
as a producer as a producer and
i mean i produced you know wish you
would with him and jose i produce stair
flu
i produce um air flow click i produce
christmas in harlem i produce [ __ ] in
paris is that
mortal kombat on let's turn that thing
off
keep going but so so in paris click i
mean you know what i'm saying it's just
like that's just
a two-year span and let alone like you
know producing stuff like my god for
pusher
producing multiple songs on john legends
i'm producing songs on big sean's
detroit one i had
i had a beat on there so just like i was
doing i did a lot of [ __ ] you did do a
lot i just think that like once that
two-year span was
up it it was it was almost like that was
like
it which y'all working together i mean
you know we both creatives
you know i'm saying we both just like it
was always something
but it's nothing but respect on my side
you know as far as the creative goals
like
when you were signed with good was it
like did they get first right refusal on
your beats
man i mean they would just take the
hardest [ __ ] so it was basically like
that anyway right i mean you know it's
funny bro at a point
i was like telling my manager like if
it's not yay
jay or beyonce like don't book no
sessions like this was that
for i don't know i can't think about how
long i was on this way but i was on that
way for a while
just like you know that's something
that's crazy to be able to even say
but you know i guess this is why when
people want to call it a resurgence now
like it's just me spreading my sound out
more just locking in with more people
and just dial in
dialing in on just that level i guess